so the monopoly is not a very perfect
monopoly and I don't think personal and
private use of mushrooms will go away
because there is fda-approved use of it
and I think it's important to realize I
mean so I'm not as terrified of that
scenario as you are I think that I think
it's really important that you have the
that medical pass even if it is a
pharmaceutical path yes because that
will make the let's and and we're all
this is all assuming that the therapy
proves out in phase three trials and
gets approved by the FDA so we're kind
of assuming that it's a big assumption
but that if it is approved in a medical
setting and doctors can prescribe it
the upside is they'll be wide access
anybody with health insurance will be
able to be covered by it so it becomes a
little less elite and a little more
accessible and that's a real positive
what does the pharmaceutical industry do
with psilocybin I think it's a kind of a
reach for them you know the problems
with Merck or some big company getting
into psychedelics are many one is
where's your intellectual property I
mean these mushrooms grow anywhere and
the even the molecule you can patent
biology now right well you can but but
not this molecule you can rat in a
delivery system a manufacturing method
but the fact is it's it's hard to get
your hands around and and have that kind
of control same with LSD that's off
patent also and so that may be one of
the reasons that big pharma doesn't so
far appear to have any interest here's
the other big problem psychedelic
therapy is a one-time or a two time or
maybe a three time thing it's not a pill
you take every day and they're in the
business of selling pills people have to
take every day like SSRIs
antidepressants so how do you make money
if you're selling two or three pills to
somebody
the course of a lifetime tell Mike
reduces yeah well Microtech just gave an
idea to migrant Oh seeing is probably a
better idea for the pharmaceutical
industry the problem with micro dosing
is no one has any idea if it's real or
not there's there's no science on
microdose it's there's science coming
now actually some is gonna be done
Beckley is proposed to do it I don't
know if that's going to get off the
ground but there's a couple other things
going on around the world but maybe in a
year or two we'll have you know one of
the reasons I didn't go into great
detail on micro dosing is that there's
no good science about it yet it could be
all placebo effect and there's nothing
wrong with that and I hope the research
doesn't louse up your placebo effect but
but yes there is a pill you take several
times a week you know you can sell that
and I can see it in little packs like
birth control pills you know with every
third you know there's there's a couple
sugar pills and then you get your micro
dose call and but so will the
pharmaceutical industry jump in